well first we'll talk about Angela
basses reaction though she first saw
them she started spanking me like oh you
bad girl I don't care what the lunar
calendar says this is the year of Ruth
Carter hey everybody
Desiree Murphy here with the mastermind
behind the costumes for Black Panther
she not only dresses the stars like
Queens but she is a queen herself Ruth
Carter let's get into the costumes cuz I
have so many questions about the female
character Sheree yeah she has I would
say the most amount of costumes in the
film you need a BIST
the design group has to offer because
she was the leader of the design design
group they were Condon Design Group that
she would be experimenting with fibers
she would be sustainable she would have
you know different more modern
approaches to her own clothes and that's
what I think made her costume really
successful because it looked like she
was moving with Conda forward that's
true
angela bassett yes from the moment we
see her on screen it's just so powerful
yes
Ramona is a part of you know the Panther
royal family and in the comics she
actually wears this headdress it's
called the Isha colo it's the married
woman's hat but also in the comics I
mean she's a little more casual she
wears a tunic and yoga pants she walks
around barefoot and so we actually
decided that you know when we first meet
Ramona at the airstrip when Black
Panther comes out of the talent fighter
that she would look like the Queen that
she does yeah and so we created her a
she colo hat as her crown and we had a
3d printed and we also created this what
I call a shoulder mantel out of African
lace and then we 3d printed that as well
so that she would have this structure
you know that she really felt like you
were you were entering a royal place and
meeting one of the royal family we also
have deny as Ocoee Okoye is the leader
of the Dorma lodge a thermal a a means
the adorned ones and she is the general
we decided that her armor would look
feel look and feel like jewelry so it
has a high Sheen we've plated it it's
inspired by the end of La tribe which
does the neck rings and the arm rings
and we made hers gold all the other
warriors wear silver a coy way wears
gold the red color was embraced because
of the beautiful ribs that we see around
Africa in the Himba tribe the Turkana
tribe the Masai tribe they all use this
you know they're all they all adore this
vibrant red and so it was important that
the red be used in the same way and also
because we could only make so many of
them and when you see one door oh you
wanted to see feel like it was an
imposing color so it felt like more if
you see three or four it felt like five
or six so that was the reason for this
you know really outstanding color yes on
the door with the squad women all coming
in yeah no power very what was your
reaction when you first saw them all
together in what you created first what
about Angela basses reaction when I
first saw them she started spanking me
like I don't know you bad girl and it
took a long time to really kind of get
that costume to where it ended up and
presenting it to people who saw it for
the first time was nerve-wracking when
Ryan came to see the final version of
the door
we had it laid out for him
he took a minute and he just really took
things in and then you know he said it's
dope they are all in red we have Lupita
in all shades of green well there was a
color palette that Ryan wanted to follow
for all of the tribes and Lupita's
character Nakia is the fighter for the
river tribe and it was important that
she wear green to represent the river
and so we used all shades of green and
it was a it was a big challenge because
I never wanted to repeat the same green
twice and up until we get to the end now
Ryan and I we we laugh and bicker
because he sees that as yellow at the UN
I see it as chartreuse when you had
green but you know it was so beautiful
against her skin and it was just like
the perfect standout
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]